It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。
I've been talking to someone here and there over the last couple of months about a situation she's in. And I think she typifies the thing we're going to try to do in this episode, so I'd like you to meet her. Her name is Annika Barber. She's a scientist, a molecular biologist at Rutgers University, a runner. She's got purple hair and a particular way of organizing the world around her-- her books, organized topically and then by height, her lab, color-coded labels.
过去几个月里，我一直在和某个人断断续续地交流，聊她所处的一种困境。我认为她是我们这期节目想要探讨的问题的典型代表，所以我想请你们认识一下她。她叫Annika Barber，是一位科学家，罗格斯大学的分子生物学家，也是一名跑步爱好者。她染着紫色的头发，对周围的世界有一套独特的整理方式——她的书按主题分类，再按高度排列；她的实验室则用颜色编码标签来管理。
I also track how many days of the year my husband eats pizza, and I make a chart of it. He's really into pizza. So sometimes I just like to have data.
我还记录了我丈夫一年里吃披萨的天数，并做了一张图表。他真的很爱吃披萨。所以我有时就是喜欢掌握数据。
Wait, wait, wait, why? Why do you do that?
等等，等等，为什么？你为什么要这样做？
So my husband really can't go 24 hours without talking about pizza. So last year, I accused him of talking about pizza every day, and he swore he didn't. And I was like, I really think you do. And so starting in January of this year, I said that for 2025, I was going to log every day that I heard him say the word pizza, as well as every time he ate pizza for the year.
因为我丈夫真的无法在24小时内不谈论披萨。去年，我指责他每天都在谈论披萨，但他发誓他没有。我就说，我真的觉得你有。所以从今年一月开始，我说在2025年，我要记录下我听到他说“披萨”这个词的每一天，以及他这一年里吃披萨的每一次。
He actually eats less pizza than I would expect for the amount he talks about pizza. Like, the consumption to discussion ratio is not what I expected it would be. He's only had pizza 14 times this year.
事实上，他吃披萨的频率比我预想的要低，考虑到他谈论披萨的次数。也就是说，消费和讨论的比例并不像我预期的那样。他今年只吃了14次披萨。
Lately, Annika has been trying to get her mind around a new situation that is deeply confusing for her and lots of people. She's tracking scientific meetings that are not happening.
最近，Annika一直在试图理解一种让她和许多人都感到非常困惑的新情况。她在追踪那些本该举行却没有举行的科学会议。
When President Trump was inaugurated, he put a freeze on research grants. This meant the meetings where scientists like Annika get together at the National Institutes of Health to assess new research-- they're called NIH study sections-- those meetings were off. But then, a judge said the administration couldn't pause all research grants, so the meetings were theoretically back on.
特朗普总统就职时，他冻结了研究经费。这意味着像Annika这样的科学家在国立卫生研究院（NIH）评估新研究的会议——也就是所谓的“NIH研究组会议”——都被取消了。但后来，一位法官裁定政府不能暂停所有研究经费，所以这些会议理论上又恢复了。
They were listed on an NIH website as scheduled, but Annika says they did not seem to be happening. The website showed they were, but scientists were saying they weren't. Scientists who had submitted grants literally had no idea if their grant had been reviewed and moved on to the next step of the funding process.
它们在NIH网站上被列为“已安排”，但Annika说这些会议似乎并没有召开。网站显示会议在进行，但科学家们却说没有。那些提交了申请书的科学家们完全不知道他们的项目是否经过了审查，以及是否进入了资助流程的下一步。
But Annika learned there was a place you could get a way better picture of whether a meeting was going to happen or had already happened.
但Annika得知，有一个地方可以让你更清楚地了解会议是否即将举行或已经举行。
I had never even heard of the federal register in my American tax-paying, voting life.
作为一个纳税和投票的美国公民，我以前甚至从未听说过《联邦公报》。
What is the federal register?
什么是《联邦公报》？
The federal register is where all notices of open public meetings that may be happening in the federal government are required to be posted. And for some reason, NIH study sections do have to be posted to the federal register at least 15 days before they meet.
《联邦公报》是联邦政府所有可能召开的公开会议通知必须发布的地方。出于某种原因，NIH的研究组会议必须在会议召开前至少15天在《联邦公报》上发布。
And if they're not posted to the federal register, they cannot meet.
如果它们没有发布在《联邦公报》上，它们就不能召开。
It's a strange feeling knowing you're in the middle of an upending, knowing that something fundamental to the way that you live is changing, but you can't understand or see the scale of change as it's happening. You just can't. You have to wait.
当你意识到自己正处于一种剧变的中心，意识到你生活方式中的某些根本性东西正在改变，但你却无法理解或看清这种变化在发生时的规模，这是一种很奇怪的感觉。你就是做不到。你只能等待。
What I like about Annika is she rejects this. She is not waiting. Annika immediately begins scraping data from federal websites, finding all the meetings that were supposed to happen, cross-referencing them with the federal register, reaching out to scientists to see if the supposedly-scheduled meetings did, in fact, occur, compiled all that into a Google spreadsheet, and posted it online.
我喜欢Annika的一点是，她拒绝等待。她没有坐以待毙。Annika立即开始从联邦网站上抓取数据，找出所有本应举行的会议，将它们与《联邦公报》进行交叉核对，联系科学家们查看这些所谓的已安排会议是否真的召开了，并将所有这些汇总到一个谷歌表格中，发布在网上。
Anxious and confused scientists all over America began consulting Annika's spreadsheet and passing it around to see is my study section actually happening? Has my grant been reviewed? Is there any point in submitting my next grant? Will I be able to keep my lab open?
全美各地焦虑而困惑的科学家们开始查阅Annika的表格，并相互传阅，看看：我的研究组会议真的在举行吗？我的申请书被审查了吗？提交下一份申请书还有意义吗？我还能维持我的实验室运作吗？
There are tens of thousands of scientists whose grants depend on this happening who are all wondering what's going on?
有数以万计的科学家，他们的研究经费取决于这些会议是否举行，他们都在想：到底发生了什么？
How much science has not happened?
有多少科学研究因此停滞了？
So let's see. Right now, we are at 182 meetings that have not happened.
让我看看。目前，已经有182场会议没有举行。
182 meetings. How many grants is that?
182场会议。那相当于多少份研究申请？
You know, if we assume roughly 100 grants would have gotten reviewed at each meeting, we're talking about at least 18,000 grants that didn't get reviewed.
你知道，如果我们假设每场会议大约会审查100份申请书，那么至少有18,000份申请书没有得到审查。
Wow.
哇。
And that's 18,000 grants across all kinds of things-- I mean, very basic science. Just scrolling through here, I've got things like adaptive immunity and bacterial virulence.
而且这18,000份申请书涵盖了各种领域——我是说，非常基础的科学。随便扫一眼，我有诸如“适应性免疫”和“细菌毒力”之类的课题。
But then we also have things like addiction risk, and learning and memory and decision making, and therapeutic immune regulation. We have training neuroscientists and physician scientists. And we have studies looking at dentistry and eye diseases, and those aren't meeting.
但我们也看到了一些课题，比如成瘾风险、学习与记忆、决策制定，以及治疗性免疫调节。我们还有正在培养的神经科学家和医生科学家。还有关于牙科和眼科疾病的研究，这些会议都没有召开。
For five weeks, there were no NIH study sections, till it was 205 study sections that did not meet. All of those proposals sat waiting, and all the ones that came after, stacking up behind them, a long traffic jam of uncertainty and science not happening.
在五周的时间里，没有任何NIH研究组会议举行，最终有205场研究组会议没能召开。所有的提案都搁置在那里，后面新提交的提案也在堆积，形成了一场关于不确定性和科学停滞的漫长交通堵塞。
And then, in March, a meeting appeared on the federal register, an NIH study section, and then another, and another. Now, the meetings to assess new research grants seem to have mostly picked back up. Scientists are doing peer reviews, but it's not clear if the government will actually cough up the money.
然后，在三月份，一场会议出现在《联邦公报》上，这是一个NIH研究组会议，接着是另一场，又一场。现在，评估新研究经费的会议似乎大部分已经恢复。科学家们正在进行同行评审，但尚不清楚政府是否真的会拿出这笔钱。
And a few of the grant proposals that were supposed to be reviewed at these meetings, they're being quietly disappeared from the lists. They're not being reviewed at all. They seem to be the grants with DEI words or other thought crimes in them that are no longer allowed. It's unclear if the scientists who submitted these grants even know that their proposals have been dropped.
而原本应该在这些会议上审查的几份研究提案，正悄悄地从名单中消失。它们根本没有被审查。它们似乎是那些包含DEI（多元、公平与包容）词汇或其他被视为“思想罪”内容的申请书，这些词汇已不再被允许。目前还不清楚这些提交申请的科学家是否知道他们的提案已经被取消了。
Annika went to a meeting herself. It was two months late, pulled together at the very last minute, but it did happen.
Annika本人也参加了一场会议。会议迟到了两个月，在最后一刻匆忙拼凑起来，但确实召开了。
We all made the time, and people were there, and people gave the same quality of review that I have always experienced in these meetings, and the same level of scientific discussion. But it felt so weird to be having these scientific discussions in this climate where you could only wonder, like, yeah, we have all these amazing scientists in this room reviewing the future of the next five years of research in the areas of molecular neurogenetics.
我们都腾出了时间，人们都到场了，大家进行的审查质量和我在这类会议上一贯经历的一样，科学讨论的水平也一样。但在这种氛围下进行这些科学讨论感觉非常奇怪，你只能纳闷，是的，我们房间里有这么多优秀的科学家在审查分子神经遗传学领域未来五年的研究方向。
But is any of this going to be funded? Are any of these studies going to go forward? Is the NIH going to give these people any money?
但这些研究能得到资助吗？这些研究能推进吗？NIH会给这些人钱吗？
Did anybody ask? Did anybody ask?
有人问过吗？有人问过吗？
No, no. Every grant gets 15 minutes for discussion, and we needed to get through 50-odd grants, so there's no time to think about anything else.
没有，没有。每份申请书只有15分钟的讨论时间，我们需要审阅50多份申请书，所以根本没时间去想别的。
So will that stuff that you reviewed get funded?
那你审阅的那些东西会得到资助吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Was there a part of you that felt like, are we chumps? Are we just like--
你内心有没有一种感觉，觉得我们是不是傻瓜？我们是不是只是……
Yes, absolutely. It feels like we're fiddling while Rome burns, talking about some cool genes, and worms, and mice, and all the interesting genome-wide association studies that we could do if money keeps existing.
是的，绝对是。感觉就像罗马在燃烧，我们却在拉小提琴一样，讨论着一些很酷的基因、蠕虫、老鼠，以及如果钱还存在的话我们本可以做的所有有趣的基因组关联研究。
Uh huh.
嗯哼。
And yeah, are we chumps? Are we participating in furthering something or nothing? Are we just wasting our time?
是的，我们是傻瓜吗？我们是在助长某种东西还是什么都没有？我们是不是在浪费时间？
The thing that is killing her is not knowing the shape of the new normal. How many grants will now be funded compared to before-- half, a quarter? Which scientists will get funding? What kind of research? There's no data she can turn to that will tell her that.
让她感到痛苦的不是不知道“新常态”的形状。与以前相比，现在有多少研究会被资助——一半，四分之一？哪些科学家会获得资助？什么样的研究？没有任何数据能告诉她这些。
And so I need the data of how bad is it? I think a lot of us are used to approaching problems as something that we can, not necessarily solve with data, but that we can find the edges of with data--
所以我需要数据来了解情况到底有多糟糕？我想我们很多人习惯于把问题当作我们可以解决的东西，不一定是通过数据解决，但我们可以通过数据找到问题的边缘——
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
--and get our arms around the problem, and define the problem by figuring out what the data are and what the--
——掌握问题的全貌，并通过找出数据是什么来定义问题，以及……
But it might be possible that that's not going to happen in this case, that there might not be--
但有可能在这一案例中，这种情况不会发生，可能根本就不会有……
That does say-- yeah, I'm starting to get that vibe. Yeah, it becomes one of those things where can you graph chaos? Maybe not. Can you feel better trying to graph chaos? Also maybe not.
确实说得对——是的，我开始感觉到这种氛围了。是的，它变成了一种“你能为混乱绘制图表吗”的问题？也许不能。尝试为混乱绘制图表能让你感觉好点吗？可能也不会。
Will she continued to try to graph the chaos? Yes, she will.
她会继续尝试为混乱绘制图表吗？是的，她会的。
Today's show is full of people who do not wait for the chaos to settle, people who run toward it, who will take whatever little data they have available to them and try to make it make sense. These are people who get answers. Stay with us.
今天的节目充满了那些不愿等待混乱平息的人，那些冲向混乱的人，他们会利用手中现有的微薄数据，试图让一切变得合理。这些人总能找到答案。请留步。
It's This American Life. The questions people are trying to answer in today's episode, they are basic-- where and why? Act One-- Solve for Why.
这里是《美国生活》。今天节目中人们试图回答的问题非常基本——在哪里？为什么？第一幕——求解“为什么”。
One of the hardest places to see through chaos in the middle of a war-- fog of war, all that. This is especially true for the war in Gaza. There is very limited information moving in and out of Gaza. Israel has banned international press from entering the strip for nearly 18 months, except for a few brief trips, accompanied by and under the control of the Israeli military.
战争中很难看清混乱——战争迷雾之类的。这对加沙战争来说尤其如此。进出加沙的信息非常有限。以色列已禁止国际媒体进入加沙地带近18个月，除了少数几次由以色列军方陪同并处于其控制之下的短暂行程。
One rare outside group has gotten a view on the ground of Gaza-- medical workers. Since the start of the war, over 100 American doctors and nurses have traveled to Gaza, treated patients there for weeks at a time, and come back out. Producer Ike Sriskandarajah talked to a dozen of them who volunteered there.
有一个罕见的外部群体在加沙实地有所见闻——医务工作者。自战争爆发以来，已有超过100名美国医生和护士前往加沙，在那里治疗伤者，每次待上几周，然后撤出。制作人Ike Sriskandarajah采访了十几位曾在那里志愿服务的医生。
Dr. Mark Perlmutter had been on about 40 medical missions all over the developing world before he went to Gaza. He's a white guy, almost 70, a hand surgeon in rural North Carolina when he's not doing humanitarian work. And when he found out patients in Gaza needed an orthopedic specialist like himself, he signed up and flew there in March of 2024. He'd worked in some pretty violent places, but never an active war zone, and only knew the basics about the conflict between Israelis and Palestinians.
Mark Perlmutter医生在去加沙之前，已经在全球发展中国家参加过约40次医疗任务。他是一位白人，快70岁了，在不进行人道主义工作时，他是北卡罗来纳州农村的一名手外科医生。当他得知加沙的伤者需要像他这样的骨科专家时，他报名并于2024年3月飞往那里。他曾在一些非常动荡的地方工作过，但从未在活跃的战区工作过，对以色列人和巴勒斯坦人之间的冲突也只了解皮毛。
I went there, only because my twist is to operate on kids who are hurt. And I knew that Gaza was 50% kids, and that's all I knew. I thought "infitada" was a type of Mexican dish. And, I mean, I knew nothing.
我去那里仅仅是因为我的特长是为受伤的孩子做手术。我知道加沙有50%的孩子，我只知道这些。我当时以为“起义”（Intifada）是一种墨西哥菜。我是说，我什么都不知道。
Intifada is the word for Palestinian uprising against Israeli occupation. But Mark was about to get a crash course from one of his fellow doctors.
“起义”是指巴勒斯坦人为反抗以色列占领而进行的起义。但Mark很快就要从他的一位同行医生那里上一门速成课了。
We got on the van, and I heard Feroze talking casually to somebody else. He's got this deep baritone voice. And, you know, you meet somebody for the first time, and within minutes you can tell that somebody is a whole lot smarter than you. And my first message was, there's absolutely no way that I'm going to get on this van and not sit next to this dude, or behind him, or within earshot of him.
我们上了车，我听到Feroze在和别人随意交谈。他的声音深沉，像男中音。你知道，当你第一次见到某人，几分钟内你就能看出对方比你聪明得多。我当时的第一想法是，我绝对不能上这辆车却不坐在他旁边，或者他后面，或者在他的听力范围内。
Dr. Feroze Sidhwa, a trauma surgeon from the US-- he's also volunteered as a doctor in the war in Ukraine and with Palestinians in the West Bank. He's closely studied the Israeli-Palestinian conflict, though his family is from a small ethnic minority in what is now Pakistan.
Feroze Sidhwa医生，来自美国的创伤外科医生——他此前也曾在乌克兰战争中以及在西岸的巴勒斯坦人中担任志愿医生。他密切研究过以巴冲突，尽管他的家人来自现在巴基斯坦境内的一个少数民族。
When people look at me, they assume I'm Palestinian or something, but I'm not. I lived in Haifa. That was from 2004 to '05, and I worked with an Arab Jewish cooperative that doesn't exist anymore. And during that time, I toured around in the West Bank-- was never able to go to Gaza, but toured around in the West Bank a lot.
当人们看着我时，他们以为我是巴勒斯坦人或其他什么，但我不是。我曾在海法住过。那是2004年到2005年，我曾与一个已经不存在的阿拉伯-犹太人合作组织一起工作。在那段时间里，我在西岸到处走访——虽然从未能去加沙，但在西岸转了很多地方。
So Mark sat next to Feroze, and when they arrived at the European Hospital-- that's the name of the hospital in Khan Younis in Gaza-- their team dropped off their thousands of pounds of supplies.
于是Mark坐在了Feroze旁边，当他们到达欧洲医院——那是汗尤尼斯加沙的一家医院的名字——时，他们的团队卸下了数千磅的物资。
European Hospital was built for just over 200 beds, but is taking care of over 1,000 people, and families are living in every corner of the hospital. Mark hadn't seen anything like it. Feroze hadn't either, but he told me he didn't linger on that long. A nurse took them on a quick tour, let them know where everything was-- the operating room, the ICU.
欧洲医院原本只有200多张床位，但现在却要照顾1,000多人，家庭住在医院的每一个角落。Mark从未见过这样的景象。Feroze也没见过，但他告诉我他没有在那上面停留太久。一名护士带他们快速参观了一下，告诉他们东西都在哪——手术室、ICU。
The nurse that was showing us around didn't really speak English very well, and she just pointed at these two kids, and just pointed at her head, and said, shot, shot. There were four kids in the hospital with gunshot wounds to the head.
带我们参观的护士英语说得不是很好，她指着两个孩子，指了指自己的头，说：“枪击，枪击。”医院里有四个头部中枪的孩子。
I just thought that that was unbelievable. And I just assumed that she was just wrong. I didn't think she was lying, but she was just incorrect. That probably was a shrapnel injury or something like that.
我当时觉得这太不可思议了。我只是以为她弄错了。我不认为她在撒谎，只是她不准确。那可能只是弹片伤之类的。
But then, I looked at these kids, and they didn't have any other evidence of an explosive injury. And then we pulled up their CT scans, and sure enough, it did look like they had been shot in the head. And then we went on and found two more kids also shot in the head in the other ICUs.
但后来，我看了这些孩子，他们身上没有其他爆炸伤的迹象。然后我们调出了他们的CT扫描，结果确实看起来像是头部中弹了。然后我们继续走，在其他ICU里又发现了两个头部中枪的孩子。
This is, like, minutes into your initial tour of the hospital. You see two kids with gunshots to the head and then two more kids with gunshots to the head.
这是你刚开始参观医院的几分钟内，你就看到了两个头部中枪的孩子，然后又看到了两个头部中枪的孩子。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, for me, what struck me about it was just the fact that it had happened. I work in a pretty rough part of the country, so I do see children who get shot in the head.
嗯哼。是的，对我来说，让我震惊的是这件事居然发生了。我在这个国家相当糟糕的一个地区工作，所以我确实见过头部中弹的孩子。
Feroze works at a hospital near Stockton, California, which has higher rates of violent crime than most of the country.
Feroze在加州斯托克顿附近的一家医院工作，那里的暴力犯罪率比全国大部分地区都要高。
But to see four kids with gunshot wounds to the head already admitted to the hospital when I get there, it certainly struck me as being very unusual.
但看到四个头部中弹的孩子在我到达时就已经被收治在医院里，这确实让我觉得非常罕见。
I mean, it was a war zone, but still, this was a lot. And then, he moved on. There were so many people that needed medical attention. The only way he could keep track of his patients was to make notes on his iPhone. Just to warn you here, the details are graphic.
我是说，那是一个战区，但这仍然太多了。然后，他继续工作。有太多人需要医疗照顾。他记录病人情况的唯一方法是在iPhone上做笔记。这里先提醒一下，细节很残酷。
Here, this is from March 28.
这是3月28日的记录。
He pulled up an entry from a random day, just to give me a sense of what it was like.
他调出了一天随意的条目，只是为了让我了解当时的情况。
Overnight, we had another mass casualty event. EMS told us a building with a large number of people in it was bombed. And then, two children arrived dead. The one I saw was 12 months old, and the other was reportedly two years old.
隔夜，我们又发生了一次大规模伤亡事件。急救人员告诉我们，一栋住着大量人的建筑被炸毁了。然后，两个孩子被送来时已经死了。我看到的那个只有12个月大，另一个据报道是两岁。
Next bullet-- I took care of a seven-year-old girl with a blast injury pneumothorax to the right lung and a bad contusion to the left lung. Next bullet-- I took care of a three-year-old child who had a massive aspiration after a head injury. Next bullet-- I took care of a 20-year-old woman with a left hemopneumothorax and depressed open skull fracture.
下一条——我救治了一个7岁的小女孩，右肺有爆炸伤导致的气胸，左肺有严重的挫伤。下一条——我救治了一个3岁的小孩，头部受伤后发生了严重误吸。下一条——我救治了一个20岁的妇女，左侧血气胸和凹陷性开放性颅骨骨折。
Next bullet-- I took care of her sister. She had almost identical injuries. Next bullet-- finally, I took care of a 25-year-old man with a frontal skull fracture and small associated subdural hematoma.
下一条——我救治了她的姐妹。她有几乎相同的伤势。下一条——最后，我救治了一个25岁的男子，额骨骨折，并伴有小的硬膜下血肿。
So that's, like, an 18-hour day.
所以那是一个18小时的工作日？
No, that was-- all of that probably happened in one hour.
不，那是……所有这些可能发生在一个小时内。
That's one hour?
那是一个小时？
That probably took about an hour or an hour and a half. Yeah.
那可能花了一个小时或一个半小时。是的。
90 minutes-- it's intense. But in that endless stream of traumatic injuries, there's one that jumped out at him every time, kids getting shot in the head. Whenever he saw this, he'd make a note of it on his phone.
90分钟——这很紧张。但在那连绵不断的创伤病例流中，有一件事每次都让他感到震惊：孩子们头部中枪。每当他看到这一点，他就会在手机上做个笔记。
And what I wrote down is that I was going through the ICU, and I found an eight-year-old girl shot in the head overnight. Her pupils are fixed and dilated. It's a transcranial gunshot wound, definitely non-survivable.
我写下来的是，我正在检查ICU，发现了一个隔夜头部中枪的8岁女孩。她的瞳孔固定并放大。这是贯通颅脑的枪伤，绝对无法存活。
This is an eight-year-old girl with a bullet wound that went through her head.
这是一个8岁的小女孩，子弹穿过了她的头。
Yeah, the bullet didn't stop. And then, let's see, the next day. So the next day, the eight-year-old girl had died, and in the same bed is a 14-year-old boy shot in the right chest and the head.
是的，子弹没有停下。然后，让我们看看，第二天。所以第二天，那个8岁的小女孩死了，在同一张床上的是一个14岁的男孩，胸部右侧和头部中枪。
The next day, I said, I went through the ICU afterwards. The 14-year-old boy turns out to be 12 when his family arrived. So then, let's see, two days later, he's been replaced by a 13-year-old boy shot in the head. I wrote, he'll also die.
第二天，我说，之后我检查了ICU。那个14岁的男孩在家人到达后，发现他其实是12岁。然后，让我们看看，两天后，他被一个13岁头部中枪的男孩取代了。我写道，他也会死。
So then on that same day, I wrote, I took care of a two-year-old girl who was brought to the ED after being shot in the head. She arrived with bilateral fixed and dilated pupils, also a non-survivable brain injury. We then had a mass casualty event a few minutes later.
所以同一天，我写道，我救治了一个2岁的小女孩，在头部中枪后被送进急诊室。她到达时双侧瞳孔固定放大，也是不可存活的脑损伤。几分钟后我们又发生了一次大规模伤亡事件。
At the same time that Feroze was starting to document this, Mark, working with his patients-- he was seeing the same thing. He vividly remembered the day he saw two kids brought in who had both been shot in the head and the chest.
在Feroze开始记录这一点时，Mark在救治他的病人时，看到了同样的事情。他清楚地记得有一天他看到两个孩子被送来，他们都头部和胸部中枪。
One of the kids was there with a family member. I ripped up his shirt, and there was a bullet entry wound right over the heart. And then I picked up the dressings on his forehead, and a second bullet went in right in front of his left ear hole, in front of his ear and out of his neck.
其中一个孩子在一位家人的陪同下。我撕开了他的衬衫，心脏上方有一个子弹入口。然后我揭开了他额头上的敷料，第二颗子弹从他左耳孔前方进去，从耳前进入，从颈部穿出。
Oh, my god. What was the kid doing when this happened?
天哪。这孩子当时在做什么？
Walking with their adult to get water.
陪着大人去取水。
Was there a street battle happening?
当时发生了街头交火吗？
I didn't ask if there was a street battle going on, but it happened twice in the same day.
我没问是不是有街头交火，但这件事在同一天发生了两次。
Could you say the second time?
能再说一次第二次吗？
Yeah, right next to that kid was another kid who got shot in the head and the chest. And that child had no adult with him, so I couldn't get a story. It's hard to see it.
是的，就在那孩子旁边是另一个头部和胸部中枪的孩子。那个孩子身边没有大人，所以我无法得知原委。这太难看了。
These weren't kids injured by collapsing buildings. They were kids who'd been shot-- direct gunshot wounds into 12-year-olds, eight-year-olds, even toddlers.
这些不是被坍塌建筑物压伤的孩子。他们是被枪击的孩子——直接对12岁、8岁甚至幼儿的头部开枪。
Oh, over a dozen, combined two injuries, only two, head or chest, a dozen others.
哦，十几例，两种伤势合并，只有两例，头部或胸部，其他十几例也是如此。
Almost every day you were there?
你待在那里的几乎每天都有？
Yeah.
是的。
By the time I left, I had seen 13 children shot in the head total, or at least that's what I recorded in my journal. I probably saw more, but I try to stick to what I actually documented.
我离开时，总共看到了13个头部中枪的孩子，或者至少是我在日记里记录下来的。我可能看到的更多，但我尽量只记录我实际证实的东西。
13 children in 14 days. Even with all the other traumatic injuries and deaths they saw, the kids who were shot really stuck with Mark. It was haunting him.
14天里有13个孩子。尽管他们还看到了其他所有创伤和死亡，但那些中枪的孩子真正困扰着Mark。它一直萦绕在他心头。
Early on, I thought it was just an isolated jerk carrying out, because every army has jerks. War changes people, and so you can absolutely have rogue people behaving inappropriately.
起初，我以为这只是一个孤立的混蛋在执行任务，因为每支军队都有混蛋。战争会改变人，所以你绝对会有那些行为不当的流氓分子。
That's as far as Mark thought about it at the time. The detail of 13 kids, all with gunshot wounds to the head and chest, it just got added to the long list of things they saw in Gaza and couldn't fully understand. It didn't come back to Feroze until they were back home and got invited to speak at a conference in Dearborn, Michigan.
Mark当时的想法仅限于此。13个孩子全部头部和胸部中枪的细节，只是被加到了他们在加沙看到且无法完全理解的事情的长名单中。直到他们回到家，并受邀在密歇根州迪尔伯恩的一次会议上发言，这事儿才回到Feroze的脑海中。
The panel had another American doctor, who also volunteered in Gaza. He worked in two different hospitals a couple months before Feroze and Mark arrived.
小组讨论还有另一位美国医生，他也曾在加沙志愿服务。他在Feroze和Mark到达前几个月曾在两家不同的医院工作。
He's a Palestinian-American in Chicago named Thaer Ahmed. And we were just sitting next to each other, talking before our panel started. And I said, I couldn't believe how many kids I saw shot in the head. I just went through my journal recently, and it was 13.
他是一位来自芝加哥的巴勒斯坦裔美国人，名叫Thaer Ahmed。在会议开始前，我们坐在一起聊天。我说，我简直不敢相信我看到那么多孩子头部中枪。我最近刚查了我的日记，是13个。
And he said, oh, yeah, I know, me, too. Almost every day, I saw a kid shot in the head. And I was like, oh, OK.
他说，哦，是的，我知道，我也是。几乎每天，我都看到一个孩子头部中枪。我就说，噢，好吧。
And then Feroze texted me, hey, this guy saw other kids shot. We have to find out who else saw other kids shot.
然后Feroze给我发短信说，嘿，这家伙也看到了其他中枪的孩子。我们得找出还有谁看到了其他中枪的孩子。
So I started asking other people who had been over there-- physicians, nurses, midwives, nurse practitioners.
所以我开始询问其他去过那里的人——医生、护士、助产士、执业护士。
I got a call from Feroze Sidhwa. I think sometime in mid-July, he called me.
我接到了Feroze Sidhwa的电话。我想是在7月中旬的某个时候，他打给我的。
Dr. Adam Hamawy is a plastic surgeon from New Jersey.
Adam Hamawy医生是来自新泽西州的整形外科医生。
And he said, did you take care of anyone with any gunshot wounds to the head or face? And I said, yes. And he said, really? How many?
他说，你救治过任何头部或面部中枪的人吗？我说，是的。他说，真的吗？有多少？
Because of Adam's specialty, he would have only seen children who survived a gunshot to the head long enough to make it to reconstructive surgery. Not many did. He saw one. It was still shocking to him.
由于Adam的专业，他只会见到那些头部中枪后存活时间长到足以进行重建手术的孩子。没几个人能做到。他见到了一个。这对他来说仍然很震惊。
Adam had served in Iraq as a surgeon in the US Army. He treated lots of injured people, but what he was seeing in Gaza was different.
Adam曾在伊拉克作为美国陆军的外科医生服役。他救治过许多受伤的人，但在加沙看到的情况却不同。
When I was in Iraq, there were civilians that were injured. There were children that were injured. And that's called incidental, collateral damage, all the terms that we use to cleanly justify what's happening. But the scale was, I mean, not even-- not even close to this.
当我在伊拉克时，确实有平民受伤。有孩子受伤。那是所谓的附带伤害，我们用来干净利落地证明正在发生的事情的所有术语。但规模，我是说，甚至——甚至根本无法与此相提并论。
I mean, I probably took care of, like, five, six children the whole time I was in Iraq, and I wasn't there for three weeks. I was there for eight months. I mean, it didn't look-- it didn't appear that they were intentional targets. Those you could really say that they were wrong place, wrong time.
我的意思是，我在伊拉克待了八个月，可能救治了五、六个孩子。我的意思是，看起来——并不像是他们是故意目标。那些你确实可以说他们是处于错误的时间、错误的地点。
I didn't see targeted gunshots to little kids that were five, six years old or 10, 15 years old. In fact, I mean, I'm thinking back. I mean, I don't think I saw a gunshot wound to a kid at all when I was there.
我没有看到针对5、6岁或10、15岁小孩子的有针对性的枪击。事实上，我是说，我在回想。我的意思是，我不认为我在那里时看到过一个孩子的枪伤。
There were documented cases where Americans did kill Iraqi children, but nothing near the scale that these doctors saw in Gaza.
有记录在案的案例表明美国人确实杀死了伊拉克儿童，但规模远不及这些医生在加沙看到的情况。
As somebody with US military experience, do you have a perspective that could explain the circumstances that lead to a kid getting shot? How do you answer that?
作为有美国军事经验的人，你有什么视角可以解释导致孩子中枪的环境吗？你如何回答这个问题？
These are little children that are being shot, and these aren't stray bullets. These are aimed. They're precise. So a stray bullet will explain one or two of them. It's not going to explain the string of precise, targeted shootings that are being done on children since October.
这些都是被枪击的小孩子，而且这些不是流弹。这些是瞄准的。它们很精确。所以流弹可以解释其中的一两起。它无法解释自10月以来针对儿童的一连串精确的、有针对性的枪击事件。
The medical worker I spoke with who spent the most time in Gaza also saw the most kids shot-- 50. She showed me a picture she took of a scan of a five or six-year-old's skull. There's a bullet in the middle of it. She was told this child was playing with their friends when an armed quadcopter drone came overhead and shot the child.
我采访的一位在加沙待的时间最长的医务人员也看到了最多的中枪儿童——50个。她给我看了她拍摄的一张5或6岁孩子头骨扫描的照片。中间有一颗子弹。她被告知这个孩子在和朋友玩耍时，一架武装四轴飞行器从头顶飞过，并射杀了这个孩子。
Dr. Ahlia Kattan also responded to Feroze's callout. She's an anesthesiologist from Southern California. She went with her husband, and between the two of them saw 15 kids who had been shot in the head or chest. The one that really stuck with her also happened to be the youngest case I'd heard of.
Ahlia Kattan医生也回应了Feroze的号召。她是来自南加州的麻醉师。她和丈夫一起去了，他们两人之间总共看到了15个头部或胸部中枪的孩子。那个让她感触最深的孩子也恰好是我听过的最小的病例。
One day, I got called in for a mass trauma in the emergency room. They said, we need help, so I assumed it was just from bombings. And this 18-month-old got thrown into my hands. Her name was Liliana.
有一天，我被叫去处理急诊室的大规模创伤。他们说，我们需要帮助，所以我以为只是炸弹引起的。这个18个月大的孩子被塞进我的怀里。她的名字叫Liliana。
I knew she was dead, but her mom was screaming, so I knew we had to do something and show her we tried. So I didn't see any blood frothing out of her mouth, and I was doing chest compressions.
我知道她已经死了，但她的妈妈在尖叫，所以我知道我们必须做些什么，向她展示我们尽力了。所以我没有看到任何血从她嘴里涌出，我正在做心肺复苏。
And I looked up at her head, and I saw there was blood. And I asked her, was there any imaging? They handed me a CT scan, and there was a bullet shot to her head, and you could tell it was like a shot right to her temple. And I was just, like, in shock to-- never have I been done this many kids, but I've never done chest compressions on a gunshot wound to an 18-month-old.
我抬头看向她的头，我看到有血。我问她，有做过影像检查吗？他们递给我一份CT扫描，那是头部中弹，你可以看出就像是射中了她的太阳穴。我当时简直，惊呆了——我从未见过这么多孩子，但我从未对一个18个月大、头部中弹的孩子进行过心肺复苏。
And the mom was just screaming. The mom, this was her only daughter, and she had tried for nine years to have her. And she was just hysterical, obviously.
那个妈妈在尖叫。妈妈，这是她唯一的女儿，她试了九年才怀上她。她显然已经崩溃了。
Feroze reached out to as many American medical workers as he could-- doctors, nurses, paramedics. He created a survey to send out and compiled all the answers. The results stunned him.
Feroze尽可能多地联系了美国医务工作者——医生、护士、护理人员。他创建了一份调查问卷发出去，并汇总了所有的回答。结果让他惊呆了。
Almost everybody had the exact same experience. Almost universally, they said the same thing, which I really was surprised by.
几乎所有人的经历都完全一样。几乎普遍地，他们说了同样的话，这让我确实感到惊讶。
Out of the 53 American medical workers surveyed who did emergency care for children in Gaza, 44 said they saw kids shot in the head or chest. Here's Mark.
在受访的53名曾为加沙儿童进行紧急护理的美国医务工作者中，44人表示他们看到过孩子头部或胸部中枪。这是Mark的情况。
83% said they saw a child who was shot in the chest or head-- 83%. So it's not just my finding.
83%的人说他们看到了头部或胸部中枪的孩子——83%。所以这不仅仅是我的发现。
Could you describe that moment when you saw just how many?
你能描述一下当你看到有多少人时那一刻的感觉吗？
Oh, I cried. Yeah, because it gave a number to the tragedy.
噢，我哭了。是的，因为这给悲剧赋予了一个数字。
Feroze published an op ed in the New York Times with the results of the survey. A group of the doctors wrote two letters to then President Biden outlining what they saw. Feroze thought that would mean two things-- they'd get a call from the White House and there'd be an investigation.
Feroze在《纽约时报》上发表了一篇专栏文章，公布了调查结果。一组医生写了两封信给当时的拜登总统，概述了他们的所见。Feroze认为这意味着两件事——他们会接到白宫的电话，而且会有调查。
I thought that any sensible Biden administration would take that New York Times article as a major opportunity to feign ignorance about what had been going on in Gaza and to say, oh, my God, we can't believe American doctors saw this. And if this is true, then we're going to have to seriously reevaluate the arms that we send to Israel.
我认为任何明智的拜登政府都会把那篇《纽约时报》文章当作一个重大机会，去假装不知道加沙发生了什么，并说，噢，天哪，我们不敢相信美国医生竟然看到了这一点。如果这是真的，那么我们将不得不重新评估我们送往以色列的武器。
I talked with three people who worked at the US State Department and reviewed allegations like this, including the person who, until recently, was the Ambassador at Large for Global Criminal Justice, a position that used to be called the War Crimes Ambassador. They all agreed the doctors' report sounded credible and significant enough to investigate.
我采访了三位在美国国务院工作并审查过此类指控的人，包括直到最近还是全球刑事司法无任所大使的人，这个职位过去被称为战争罪行大使。他们都同意医生的报告听起来可信且重要到足以进行调查。
Each of them said the next step should be asking Israel for answers. One, who is involved in vetting US weapons transfers, told me if this had been another country other than Israel, this is what would have happened.
他们每个人都说下一步应该是要求以色列给出答案。其中一位参与审查美国武器转让的人告诉我，如果这发生在除以色列以外的另一个国家，这就是会发生的事情。
A few years ago, a senior member of the House Foreign Affairs Committee received reports that Mexican marine units were executing and disappearing people. The US stopped a shipment of machine guns for more than two years while they investigated the allegations. Eventually, Mexico agreed that American weapons wouldn't go to those units.
几年前，众议院外交事务委员会的一名高级成员收到报告称，墨西哥海军部队在处决和失踪人员。美国停止了一批机枪的运输超过两年，同时调查这些指控。最终，墨西哥同意美国武器不会流向这些部队。
But that isn't what happened here. The Biden administration never met with Feroze and Mark. They didn't investigate these claims or make any public statements asking Israel to stop shooting kids in Gaza. They didn't try to get to the bottom of these allegations.
但这在这里并没有发生。拜登政府从未与Feroze和Mark会面。他们没有调查这些主张，也没有发表任何公开声明要求以色列停止在加沙射杀儿童。他们没有试图查清这些指控的真相。
I read these doctors' accounts and had the same question they asked in one of their letters to President Biden. How could this be a series of accidents, such widespread shooting of so many young children over the course of an entire year? But I've also reported on war crimes before, and I know that cases that seem to a bystander, or even a doctor on the ground, like clear acts of atrocity-- they can be explained as a tragic but expected part of war, allowable under the rules of war.
我读了这些医生的叙述，提出了他们在写给拜登总统的一封信中问的同样的问题：这怎么可能是一系列事故，在整整一年里如此广泛地射杀这么多幼童？但我以前也报道过战争罪行，我知道那些对于旁观者，甚至对于实地医生来说看起来像是清晰的暴行行为的案例——它们可以被解释为战争中悲剧但预料之中的一部分，在战争规则下是允许的。
The Gaza Strip is a small, densely populated place. It's nearly 50% children. Hamas is hiding inside that population. Any fighting between Hamas and Israel will have civilian casualties, including children.
加沙地带是一个人口稠密的小地方。其中近50%是儿童。哈马斯隐藏在那个人口中。哈马斯和以色列之间的任何战斗都会导致平民伤亡，包括儿童。
So we asked the Israel Defense Forces how they explained the reports from American medical workers. They declined both my interview requests, but sent a statement, saying, "The IDF does not target minors and takes extensive measures to prevent harm to civilians, including children. The IDF is committed to mitigating civilian harm and operates in full compliance with international legal obligations. For security reasons, we cannot elaborate on operational policies."
所以我们问以色列国防军他们如何解释美国医务工作者的报告。他们拒绝了我的采访要求，但发了一份声明，称：“以色列国防军不以未成年人为目标，并采取了广泛的措施来防止伤害平民，包括儿童。以色列国防军致力于减轻平民伤害，并完全遵守国际法律义务运营。出于安全原因，我们无法阐述作战政策。”
Which doesn't explain why so many kids were getting shot. So I went looking for an Israeli soldier who'd served in Gaza, who could tell me what it was like on the ground and what the rules were on who they could shoot in what circumstances. And we found one who would talk with us. He's a reservist in his early 30s, a grad student whose unit got called up at the beginning of the war. He asked us to just call him M. He was worried about retribution, so we had an actor read his responses to my questions.
这并没有解释为什么这么多孩子会中弹。所以我去寻找一名曾在加沙服役的以色列士兵，他可以告诉我实地的情况，以及在什么情况下可以射击的规则是什么。我们找到了一个愿意和我们交谈的人。他是一名30岁出头的预备役军人，一名研究生，他的部队在战争初期被征召。他请我们只叫他“M”。他担心受到报复，所以我们请了一位演员朗读他对我问题的回答。
It varied a lot, but a typical day was we'd have some missions, looking for weapons, looking for tunnels. And if we see anybody, engage them. And my role was the front machine gunner, light machine gunner.
情况差异很大，但典型的一天是我们会有一些任务，寻找武器，寻找地道。如果我们看到任何人，就与他们交战。而我的角色是前线机枪手，轻机枪手。
His company started in the north of Gaza, not near the hospital where Feroze and Mark and most of the doctors were. He said there was a humanitarian road running north and south, and near the humanitarian road, the rules of engagement were don't shoot unless there's an immediate threat. But once you got away from the humanitarian road--
他的连队始于加沙北部，不在Feroze、Mark和大多数医生所在的医院附近。他说有一条南北向的人道主义道路，在人道主义道路附近，交战规则是除非有直接威胁，否则不要射击。但一旦你远离了人道主义道路——
Everything besides that, we're told no one is supposed to be there. The orders to evacuate have been made. Anyone who is there is not supposed to be there. For us, basically the guidance was, men of fighting age, shoot. It doesn't matter if they're armed or not. They're not supposed to be there. And the logic being that Hamas operators, they don't walk around armed. They keep weapons caches in different homes. They walk around. They run to the nearest house if they need a weapon. So any basically men, you shoot on sight.
除了那之外的一切，我们被告知不应该有任何人。撤离令已经发布。任何在那里的人都不应该在那里。对我们来说，基本上指导原则是，战斗年龄的男性，射击。不管他们是否携带武器。他们不应该在那里。逻辑是，哈马斯人员，他们不会带着武器走动。他们把武器库存放在不同的房子里。他们四处走动。如果需要武器，他们会跑到最近的房子。所以基本上任何男性，你见就射。
And that's--
那是——
And it's shoot to kill.
而且是击毙。
Shoot to kill.
击毙。
If it's a woman and child, use the standard kind of non-war procedure where you just detain them-- try to detain them. This is how we heard it from the commanders. Don't shoot women and children unless they're a threat. Try to just detain them.
如果是妇女和儿童，使用标准的非战争程序，你只是拘留他们——试着拘留他们。这是我们从指挥官那里听到的。不要射击妇女和儿童，除非他们是威胁。尽量只是拘留他们。
He says there was one incident where his unit did see two young people they thought might be a threat. One day, when two teenagers, 14 or 15, were part of a convoy going south, they sprinted away and ran into a building. A Hummer and a tank followed them and ordered them to come out. The army thought the teens might be luring them into a trap. When the teens didn't come out, they fired at the building, killing them.
他说有一次他的部队确实看到了两个他们认为可能是威胁的年轻人。有一天，当两个14或15岁的少年成为向南行进的车队的一部分时，他们冲了出去并跑进了一栋楼。一辆悍马车和一辆坦克跟随他们，命令他们出来。军队认为少年们可能在引诱他们进入陷阱。当少年们没有出来时，他们向建筑物开火，杀死了他们。
He says his unit never fired on any other teenagers or little kids. But, he says, different units operate differently.
他说他的连队从未向任何其他青少年或小孩开火。但是，他说，不同的部队运作方式不同。
The Israeli army is not the US Army. There's much more kind of DIY element. It comes down to your commander, how he decides, the standards he sets. And our company commander happens to be a kibbutznik, who is a little bit more cautious and doesn't want to essentially create a [BLEEP] storm.
以色列军队不是美国军队。有更多DIY元素。这归结于你的指挥官，他如何决定，他设定的标准。我们的连长恰好是一个基布兹社员，他稍微谨慎一点，不想从本质上制造一场烂摊子。
It matters who your commander is.
谁是你的指挥官很重要。
Yeah. I can tell you there are soldiers in the unit who are hardcore, right wing settlers who, if it was up to them, we could be doing much more damage.
是的。我可以告诉你，部队里有一些铁杆的、右翼定居者，如果由他们决定，我们可以造成更大的破坏。
I remember there was another company in the battalion, their company commander, very much not like ours. I was at an observation post, and he comes by just to look through my binoculars. And he sees a Gazan family passing by some Shaldag soldiers, and he sees them giving the family bottled water. And he goes on the radio to yell at them, saying, what are you doing? You want to open up a lemonade stand, too?
我记得营里还有另一个连队，他们的连长，非常不像我们那个。我在一个观察哨，他走过来只是为了透过我的望远镜看。他看到一个加沙家庭经过一些Shaldag士兵，他看到他们给那个家庭瓶装水。他在无线电里对他们大喊大叫，说，你们在干什么？你们也想开个柠檬水摊吗？
And he starts looking through my binoculars and calling orders to some bulldozers, saying, see that line of trees over there? See that? Take them all down. Destroy all of that. And I ask, oh, are you doing an operation there later and for security, you don't want them to have any kind of sniper positions? And he said, no, just don't let them live. He was pretty much operating from make it as difficult for their lives as possible going forward.
他开始透过我的望远镜看，并向一些推土机发出命令，说，看到那边那排树了吗？看到那个了吗？把它们全部砍掉。摧毁所有这一切。我问，噢，你们以后要在那里执行行动，为了安全，你们不希望他们有任何狙击阵地吗？他说，不，只是不要让他们活下去。他基本上是在执行“尽可能让他们未来的生活困难”的方针。
So according to M, the broad permission to fire, and the types of units led by more aggressive company commanders, you can see how that could result in soldiers shooting Palestinian children. He didn't see this himself. This is just his opinion, he told me. But he believes that Israeli soldiers have probably shot some children on purpose.
所以根据M的说法，广泛的射击许可，以及由更具攻击性的连长领导的部队类型，你可以看出这可能导致士兵射杀巴勒斯坦儿童。他自己没有亲眼见到。他告诉我，这只是他的观点。但他相信以色列士兵很可能故意射杀了一些儿童。
At least some of these cases I can see being intentional. It wouldn't shock me. They're in the situation, and they get desensitized really fast, and develop a hatred really fast. So no way to justify that. I do understand the mentality.
至少其中一些案例我认为是有意为之。我不会感到震惊。他们处于这种情况下，他们很快就会脱敏，很快就会产生仇恨。所以无法证明这一点。我确实理解这种心态。
At first, shooting unarmed people was horrifying to us. It's like, I can't believe we did that. And then it was like, ugh. Like, you get desensitized to it. And after you lose some friends, you start thinking, why even take the chance? Our lives are more important than theirs. I won't bet my life on it that they're Hamas, but I'll bet their lives on it that they're Hamas, essentially.
起初，射杀手无寸铁的人让我们感到恐惧。就像是，我不敢相信我们做了那种事。然后就像是，呃。就像，你对它脱敏了。在你失去一些朋友后，你开始想，为什么要冒这个险？我们的生命比他们的重要。我不会拿我的生命打赌他们是哈马斯，但我会拿他们的生命打赌他们是哈马斯，本质上。
So regarding this American doctors seeing the children, no, I can only give my take that some soldier took it upon themselves, said, OK, they're an age like this that I can rationalize to myself that they're potentially combatants. Why take the chance?
所以关于美国医生看到儿童这一点，不，我只能给出我的看法，即某些士兵自作主张，说，好吧，他们处于这种年龄，我可以说服自己他们是潜在的战斗人员。为什么要冒这个险？
I could just tell you, based on the dozen conversations I've had, they're talking about children who are as young as-- this is hard to say-- but 18 months who have been shot.
我只能告诉你，基于我进行的十几场对话，他们谈论的是像——这很难说——但18个月大的孩子被枪击了。
Well, the 18-month-old, there's no-- there's no question there.
好吧，18个月大的那个，没有任何——没有任何疑问。
Yeah.
是的。
And I don't think anything-- I can't give a reason. I mean, the simple one of crossfire, et cetera, that's one. But if they're saying there was one shot exactly and no other wounds, then that goes out the window.
而且我不认为任何——我无法给出理由。我的意思是，简单的交叉火力之类的，这是一种。但如果他们说是一次射击且没有其他伤口，那么这就站不住脚了。
I asked M for other possible explanations. What if the soldiers didn't know they were kids? It's a chaotic, tense environment full of people and places to hide. That could happen.
我问M有没有其他可能的解释。如果士兵不知道他们是孩子呢？这是一个混乱、紧张的环境，到处都是人和可以躲藏的地方。那可能会发生。
But he and another IDF soldier I spoke with, someone who didn't serve in Gaza but whose job was to identify targets for snipers, said it wasn't hard to distinguish a child from an adult. It wouldn't explain an 18-month-old being precisely shot in the head, or toddlers, or other grade school age kids.
但他和另一位我采访过的以色列国防军士兵，一个没在加沙服役但工作是为狙击手识别目标的人，都说区分孩子和成年人并不难。这无法解释一个18个月大的孩子被精确地射击头部，或者幼儿，或其他学龄儿童。
Were the kids being used as human shields by Hamas, or even victims of Hamas in a false flag operation to blame Israel and draw sympathy? M hadn't heard of that happening in Gaza and hadn't seen it. He says when he tries to make sense of what happened, there's been a societal shift in Israel that he thinks is a factor.
这些孩子是被哈马斯用作人盾，甚至是哈马斯在假旗行动中的受害者，用以指责以色列并博取同情吗？M没听说过加沙发生过这种事，也没见过。他说当他试图理解发生的事情时，以色列社会发生了转变，他认为这是一个因素。
I hear enough attitudes and opinions that would have shocked me 10 years ago. Now, it's like yeah, this is how people feel here.
我听到了足够的态度和观点，这在10年前会让我震惊。现在，就像是是的，这就是这里人们的感觉。
I have a friend whose dad said in an interview he was in the Mossad and basically said that no one in Gaza over the age of 4 is innocent. So this isn't a fringe mentality among Israelis. No one in Gaza is innocent. They all support Hamas, of all ages. Where they draw the line varies. But they'll say anyone that's self-aware in Gaza is a Hamas supporter.
我有一个朋友，他的父亲在一次采访中说他在摩萨德工作，基本上说在加沙，4岁以上的人没有一个是无辜的。所以这在以色列人中不是一种边缘心态。在加沙，没有人是无辜的。他们都支持哈马斯，无论年龄大小。他们划定界限的地方各不相同。但他们会说在加沙任何有自我意识的人都是哈马斯支持者。
The Israeli army has not announced any investigations into the shooting of children in Gaza. In the meantime, the Trump administration just authorized another $12 billion in arms sales to Israel. That's in addition to the reported $17.9 billion the US has given Israel in military aid since the war began.
以色列军队尚未宣布对加沙射杀儿童的事件进行任何调查。与此同时，特朗普政府刚刚批准了向以色列出售价值120亿美元的武器。这还不包括自战争开始以来美国向以色列提供的据报道价值179亿美元的军事援助。
The kids getting shot like this are a tiny part of the large number of casualties in Gaza. At least 65,000 people have been killed, more than 15,000 of them children. An expert who investigates war crimes described it as a haystack of needles.
像这样中枪的孩子只是加沙大量伤亡中的一小部分。至少有65,000人被杀，其中超过15,000人是儿童。一位调查战争罪行的专家将其描述为“草堆里的针”。
Most of these allegations will never find their way to court, so sometimes, in cases like these, war crimes investigators look for emblematic crimes, clear instances of violence outside of the rules of war that tell us something about the war, like the My Lai Massacre, Srebrenica, the chemical weapons attacks in Syria.
这些指控中的大多数永远不会进入法庭，所以有时，在这些案例中，战争罪行调查人员会寻找具有象征意义的罪行，即战争规则之外的明确暴力实例，这些实例告诉我们一些关于这场战争的信息，比如美莱村大屠杀、斯雷布雷尼察、叙利亚的化学武器袭击。
What do these deaths tell us? The hundreds of kids American medical workers saw shot in the head and chest, what are they emblematic of? They tell us it's likely that an Israeli soldier can shoot a child in Gaza on purpose with no consequence, and the US isn't going to try to stop it.
这些死亡告诉我们什么？数百名美国医务工作者看到头部和胸部中枪的孩子，它们象征着什么？它们告诉我们，以色列士兵很可能在加沙故意射杀一名儿童而不受任何惩罚，而美国并不打算阻止它。
Ike Sriskandarajah is a producer on our show. Avi Vichner is the actor who read for M.
Ike Sriskandarajah是我们节目的制作人。Avi Vichner是为M朗读的演员。
Coming up, a woman discovers she is a central data point in a story she did not know was unfolding. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一名女子发现自己是她并不知道正在展开的故事中的一个核心数据点。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, Chaos Graph, people trying to make sense of things, trying to map what is happening around them and see the bigger picture. We've arrived at Act Two-- Solve for Where.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass。今天的节目，“混乱图表”，人们试图理清事情，试图绘制他们周围正在发生的事情并看到更大的图景。我们到达了第二幕——求解“在哪里”。
In this next story, the bigger picture has become very clear to the rest of us over the last couple of weeks. It's in the news all the time. But the woman at the center of this story, she experienced it up close. She learned each fact in the most personal, direct way, and making sense of those facts, understanding how they all fit together for her was urgent. Nadia Reiman has her story.
在这个接下来的故事中，更大的图景在过去几周里对我们其他人来说变得非常清晰。新闻里到处都是。但这个故事中心的那位女性，她近距离经历了这一切。她以最个人、最直接的方式学习了每一个事实，而理解这些事实，理解它们如何为她拼凑在一起是紧迫的。Nadia Reiman带来了她的故事。
When Mari shows me this video, it feels like something I'm not supposed to be watching. On the screen is her fiance, Mikael. He's shirtless. He's crisply lined up. He's young, 23, bright green eyes, wild curly hair tucked under a baseball cap, and he's holding a tattoo gun, giving himself a tattoo on his stomach while she teases him, says he's never going to tattoo her again.
当Mari给我看这段视频时，感觉就像我不应该看的东西。屏幕上是她的未婚夫，Mikael。他赤裸着上身。他身材匀称。他很年轻，23岁，有着明亮的绿色眼睛，蓬乱的卷发塞在棒球帽下，他手里拿着纹身枪，正在给自己的肚子纹身，而她逗他，说他再也不会纹她了。
[MIKAEL LAUGHING]
[MIKAEL大笑]
He looks up and laughs, his mouth full of braces. Mari is always sort of dragging Mikael about his tattoos. He has lots of them, some which Mari finds offensively dumb.
他抬头大笑，满嘴牙套。Mari总是因为Mikael的纹身而对他有点“拖后腿”。他有很多纹身，Mari觉得有些令人反感地愚蠢。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He has a Mickey Mouse, but the Mickey Mouse is smoking. He used to smoke, and he used to do ridiculous things like that, because to me, they're ridiculous things. But yeah.
他有一个米老鼠，但米老鼠在抽烟。他以前抽烟，而且他过去做一些类似那样荒谬的事情，因为对我来说，它们是荒谬的事情。但是，是的。
And then behind that, he has a little hand, like a little hand with an eye. And he tells me that eye sees everything. And I was just like, bueno, OK.
在那之后，他有一只小手，像一只带着眼睛的小手。他告诉我那只眼睛能看见一切。我就说，好的，好吧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And he has something else there, like just-- like an ugly doll, like it looks like a toad. It has big eyes.
他那里还有别的东西，像……就像一个丑娃娃，看起来像一只蟾蜍。它有大眼睛。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's ET smoking a blunt. Mari is not her real name. She's from Venezuela. She's here applying for asylum, which is legal, but that seems to matter less and less nowadays in terms of who gets deported, hence the alias.
那是外星人在抽大麻。Mari不是她的真名。她来自委内瑞拉。她在这里申请庇护，这是合法的，但考虑到谁会被驱逐出境，这似乎在当今变得越来越不重要，因此用了化名。
Mari and Mikael are the kind couple who wear matching outfits-- her idea, but she insists he's also into it, shows me a picture where they're wearing matching pink shorts that he chose. Mikael is a barber. Mari works cleaning hotels, so they work opposite hours. She gets up early, goes to bed early. He gets up later, goes to bed later. When their schedules do match up, they're usually so tired that they sit at home and watch TV on their fuzzy pink bedspread.
Mari和Mikael是那种穿情侣装的可爱夫妻——她的主意，但她坚持说他也喜欢，给我看了一张照片，照片里他们穿着他挑的粉色情侣短裤。Mikael是理发师。Mari在酒店做清洁工作，所以他们的工作时间是错开的。她起得早，睡得早。他起得晚，睡得晚。当他们的时间表一致时，他们通常累得坐在一起在他们毛茸茸的粉色床上看电视。
The morning it happened, Mari left early, like she usually does. She noticed a bunch of men outside. They were dressed in black, she says. One of them spoke Spanish. They came up to her, her roommate, and her landlord.
事情发生的那天早上，Mari像往常一样早早离开了。她注意到外面有一群男人。她说他们穿着黑色衣服。其中一个说西班牙语。他们走到她、她的室友和她的房东面前。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The owner of the house stands up, and he looks out the window, and he sees a few police outside. And they show him a photo, and they ask him for un muchacho, for a guy. And he says, no, he doesn't live here, but three other people live here.
房主站起来，向窗外看，他看到外面有几个警察。他们给他看了一张照片，问他要一个年轻人。他说，不，他不住在这里，但这里住了其他三个人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It seemed like they were looking for someone. One of them showed her the photo on his phone. He was like, do you know this person?
看起来他们在找人。其中一个在手机上给她看了照片。他说，你认识这个人吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He was a dark-skinned person with dark hair. He had big eyes. He had a beard. We didn't really know who he was. And they tell us that he's Dominican.
他是一个皮肤黝黑、头发深色的人。他有大眼睛。他留着胡子。我们真的不知道他是谁。他们告诉我们他是多米尼加人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And he tells us that they're going to check the house to just make sure and to verify, to make sure it's true that that person that they're looking for doesn't live here. I really didn't see a problem with it because we haven't committed any crime. We're not hiding anything.
他告诉我们他们要搜查房子，只是为了确认并核实，确保他们正在找的那个人真的不住在这里。我真的没觉得有什么问题，因为我们没有犯任何罪。我们没有隐瞒任何事情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Mari figured she and Mikael had applied for asylum. He had his first court hearing already. His next one was coming up. They didn't think they were in any danger, so Mari sees no problem with letting any sort of law enforcement in. So she opens the gate, leads them down these narrow gray steps and into her basement apartment, where Mikael was still asleep.
Mari想，她和Mikael已经申请了庇护。他已经完成了第一次法庭听证。他的下一次听证会即将到来。他们不觉得自己在危险之中，所以Mari觉得让任何类型的执法人员进来都没有问题。所以她打开大门，带他们走下狭窄的灰色台阶，进入她的地下室公寓，Mikael还在那里睡觉。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So they went downstairs, and, obviously, I went first, because I was there to wake him up. He was half asleep, and he says, what's happening? He sat up, and when he sat up, well, he usually sleeps naked. I hand him a towel, and I tell him put the towel on because [SPEAKING SPANISH]. The police is coming.
他们下楼了，显然我走在前面，因为我是去叫醒他的。他睡眼朦胧，他说，怎么了？他坐起来，当他坐起来时，好吧，他通常裸睡。我递给他一条毛巾，告诉他把毛巾围上，因为……[说西班牙语]。警察来了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
They came in. They pushed the door. They put me in handcuffs. They put him in handcuffs. And the moment that happened, I said, well, what's happening? Why are you putting us in handcuffs?
他们进来了。他们推开了门。他们给我戴上手铐。他们给他戴上手铐。那一刻，我说，好吧，发生了什么？你们为什么要给我们戴上手铐？
And then I started crying. I started crying, and he would tell me, niña, tranquila. Niña, calm down. And I kept on crying, and I was asking, why are we in handcuffs? Why are they doing this? But they didn't tell me anything.
然后我开始哭。我开始哭，他会告诉我，小姑娘，冷静点。小姑娘，冷静下来。我一直在哭，我在问，为什么我们戴着手铐？为什么他们要这样做？但他们什么都没告诉我。
The only thing they were saying, stay calm, because things can get worse. And if he moved, whatever movement he made, they would sit him down. I mean, he couldn't do anything. He couldn't move.
他们唯一说的是，保持冷静，因为事情可能会变得更糟。如果他移动，无论他做了什么动作，他们就会让他坐下。我的意思是，他什么也做不了。他无法移动。
Did they identify themselves? Did they tell you they were from ICE?
他们表明身份了吗？他们告诉你他们是移民局的吗？
No.
没有。
The men in black, Mari would later learn, were maybe ICE, Immigrations and Customs Enforcement, or maybe police working with ICE and the DEA for some reason. We don't know for sure, because they won't answer any of my questions.
Mari后来才知道，那些黑衣人可能是移民和海关执法局（ICE），或者是出于某种原因与ICE和缉毒局（DEA）合作的警察。我们不能确定，因为他们不会回答我的任何问题。
What we do know is that Mikael ends up one of the 238 men who are in the news now almost every day, men who were sent away to a prison in El Salvador, where no one can reach them. And the president has refused to try to get them back, despite a court suggesting he should.
我们所知道的是，Mikael最终成为了现在每天新闻里都会提到的238名男子之一，这些男子被送往萨尔瓦多的一所监狱，在那里没有人能联系到他们。尽管有法院建议应该努力接回他们，但总统拒绝了。
But that's all in the future. On that day in February, Mari says there was one of them, one of the men in black, that spoke Spanish. He started talking to Mikael. He was calmer.
但那都是以后的事了。在二月的那一天，Mari说他们中有一个人，那个说西班牙语的黑衣人，开始和Mikael交谈。他更冷静。
He was like, it's OK, man, just be cool. Don't move too much. It's going to be fine. He translates for the rest. He tells Mari that they are taking Mikael, that they need to question him, but that she is free to go. Mari is in a daze. She doesn't know why they are taking him but letting her go.
他说，没关系，伙计，酷一点。不要动太多。会没事的。他为其他人翻译。他告诉Mari，他们要带走Mikael，他们需要盘问他，但她可以自由离开。Mari处于恍惚状态。她不知道他们为什么带走他却放她走。
They uncuff her. They let Mikael get dressed. The one that speaks Spanish tells Mari that they're taking him to Federal Plaza, an ICE office in Manhattan. And then, it's over. The men in uniforms take Mikael away, and Mari is left looking around, wondering what just happened.
他们解开她的手铐。他们让Mikael穿好衣服。那个说西班牙语的人告诉Mari，他们要把他带到联邦广场，那是位于曼哈顿的ICE办公室。然后，一切都结束了。身着制服的男人们带走了Mikael，Mari留在原地环顾四周，想知道刚才发生了什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I didn't know what to do, so the first thing I did was-- I don't know. I went to work.
我不知道该怎么办，所以我做的第一件事是……我不知道。我去工作了。
You went to work after that?
在那之后你去工作了？
Si. Si.
是的。是的。
Why?
为什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I didn't know what to do. I thought to myself, look, I'll go to work. I'll look for help. I just didn't know what to do. I didn't know. Everything felt stuck. I've never gone through something like this.
我不知道该怎么办。我对自己说，看，我去工作。我会寻求帮助。我只是不知道该怎么办。我不知道。一切都感觉被卡住了。我从来没有经历过这样的事情。
Not going to work is not an option for Mari. She's been working since she was about 16, no matter what's happening around her. Her boss told me that she's never met someone so young yet so serious, reliable. She's the only one in her family who has left the country, the problem solver, the one her mom likes best, she said.
不去工作对Mari来说不是一个选择。无论周围发生了什么，她从16岁左右就开始工作了。她的老板告诉我，她从未见过如此年轻却又如此认真、可靠的人。她是她家里唯一离开国家的人，是解决问题的人，是她妈妈最喜欢的人，她说。
I asked her, would your mom agree? And without missing a beat, she said, I will FaceTime her right now and you can ask her yourself.
我问她，你妈妈会同意吗？她毫不犹豫地说，我现在就跟她视频通话，你可以亲自问她。
Mari met Mikael in Colombia three years ago. She was 21. He kept hanging out at the boutique where she worked and one day, she mentioned she wanted a tattoo. He was like, I'll do it for you. She was skeptical but agreed.
Mari三年前在哥伦比亚遇到了Mikael。她当时21岁。他总是去她工作的精品店，有一天，她提到想要纹身。他说，我帮你纹。她持怀疑态度，但还是同意了。
From the moment they started dating, they were inseparable. Mari told me she has a temper and liked that Mikael could handle it. She says he's funny and charming, a little more shameless than she is.
从他们开始约会的那一刻起，他们就形影不离。Mari告诉我她脾气暴躁，喜欢Mikael能应付她的脾气。她说他既风趣又有魅力，比她稍微厚脸皮一点。
When they traveled up to the US, if they needed to ask for food, Mari always felt embarrassed. Not Mikael. He made friends with everybody.
当他们前往美国时，如果他们需要要食物，Mari总是觉得尴尬。Mikael不会。他与每个人都成了朋友。
When they got to New York and their hours didn't match up, they spent what seems to me like basically their whole day video calling. When she got off the train in the morning, call from Mikael. When he got out of the shower, call from Mikael. At lunchtime, call from Mikael. While he's cutting hair, call from Mikael. They knew where the other was, what the other was doing, what the other was eating all the time, until now.
当他们到达纽约，工作时间错开时，他们花的时间看起来就像几乎整天都在视频通话。早上她下火车时，有Mikael的电话。他洗完澡出来时，有Mikael的电话。午饭时间，有Mikael的电话。当他在剪头发时，有Mikael的电话。他们一直知道对方在哪里，在做什么，在吃什么，直到现在。
Mari is at a loss. She doesn't understand why Mikael would be in trouble. So she turns to the first person she trusts that knows this crazy system to see if she can help her make sense of what's going on, her boss at the hotel, a woman from Ecuador who's also an immigrant but a citizen.
Mari束手无策。她不明白Mikael为什么会有麻烦。所以她求助于她信任的第一个了解这种疯狂系统的人，看看她能不能帮她弄清楚发生了什么，就是她在酒店的老板，一位来自厄瓜多尔的女性，她也是移民，但已经是公民了。
Her boss always told her employees if they were ever in trouble with immigration, come to her, no problem. So even though it made Mari feel a little embarrassed to ask for help, she did it.
她的老板总是告诉员工，如果他们遇到移民问题，就来找她，没问题。所以尽管这让Mari觉得请求帮助有点尴尬，但她还是做了。
Mari's boss helped Mari find Mikael online through an ICE website. And it shows that, indeed, Mikael is being held in New York. That afternoon, he calls and tells Mari that they had to hold him there, even though there was no criminal record of him.
Mari的老板帮Mari在网上通过ICE网站找到了Mikael。它确实显示Mikael被关在纽约。那天下午，他打电话告诉Mari，尽管他没有犯罪记录，但他们必须把他关在那里。
That night, Mari tracks him online again and sees that he's now in Pennsylvania. She thinks, why are they moving him?
那天晚上，Mari再次在网上追踪他，看到他现在在宾夕法尼亚州。她想，为什么要转移他？
Mari's boss tells her get a lawyer, like yesterday, so she starts to look for one. She needs one that she can afford and that speaks Spanish. It took her a week to find one. The lawyer looks into Mikael's case right away, trying to figure out why he got detained in the first place.
Mari的老板告诉她赶紧找个律师，于是她开始找。她需要一个她负担得起且讲西班牙语的律师。她花了一周时间才找到。律师立即开始研究Mikael的案件，试图弄清楚他当初为什么被拘留。
Much to the lawyer's distaste, Mari, a true gen Z'er, starts to post a lot on TikTok. Almost overnight, her feed morphs from dancing reggaeton videos to photo collages of Mikael set to cheesy Spanish ballads, laying out their story, asking people to make it go viral.
令律师不悦的是，作为一个真正的Z世代，Mari开始在TikTok上大量发帖。几乎一夜之间，她的动态就从雷鬼舞视频变成了配有俗气西班牙语情歌的Mikael照片拼贴，展示了他们的故事，要求人们让它疯传。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Mari is particularly concerned with Mikael being moved to Pennsylvania like that, without him consenting to it. The lawyer tells her, don't worry about that part. The government can move him around detention centers all they want. They just can't deport him. A judge has to decide that.
Mari特别担心Mikael被转移到宾夕法尼亚州，他并没有同意。律师告诉她，不要担心那部分。政府可以随意把他转移到各个拘留中心。他们只是不能驱逐他。法官必须决定。
So for the next few weeks, all of these moving parts become Mari's new normal-- TikToks about Mikael, calls with the lawyer, video calls from the Pennsylvania detention center.
所以接下来的几周，所有这些变动的组成部分成了Mari的新常态——关于Mikael的TikTok，与律师的通话，来自宾夕法尼亚拘留中心的视频电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Four or five times a day was him calling me, me calming him down, me telling him he was going to get out of there, to have faith.
一天四五次是他打电话给我，我安慰他，我告诉他他会出来的，要相信。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then, one day in March, she doesn't hear from him for hours.
然后，三月的一天，她几个小时没收到他的消息。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then he called me. He called me at 4:00 in the morning, and he tells me, crying desperately, niña, they transferred me again to El Valle, to Texas. I was the whole time on a plane. They didn't tell me anything. I didn't eat. I didn't drink water. They didn't give us anything. I haven't been able to sleep. They're going to process me here.
然后他打电话给我。他在凌晨4点打电话给我，绝望地哭着告诉我，小姑娘，他们又把我转移到El Valle了，去德克萨斯州。我全程都在飞机上。他们什么都没告诉我。我没吃东西。我没喝水。他们什么都没给我们。我一直没法睡觉。他们要在这里处理我。
And me, bueno niño, calm down. Be strong. You're going to leave. Remember that on Monday, you have your court appointment. If we have to pay bail, we'll pay bail. But you're going to-- you're going to leave. You're going to get out of there.
而我，好的小姑娘，冷静点。要坚强。你会离开的。记住周一你有法庭预约。如果我们必须付保释金，我们会付保释金。但你会——你会离开的。你会从那里出来的。
Mari checks the website, and indeed, there he is in Texas, so much further away from her, from their little basement apartment. She's like, why are they taking him further away?
Mari查了网站，确实，他在德克萨斯州，离她、离他们的小地下室公寓远得多了。她说，为什么要带他去更远的地方？
She calls the lawyer, who tells her, again, don't worry, they can move him, but they can't deport him. Which is true, at least legally speaking. Mari had a bad feeling, but she pushed it down and went to work.
她打电话给律师，律师又告诉她，不要担心，他们可以转移他，但他们不能驱逐他。这是事实，至少在法律层面上是这样。Mari有一种不好的预感，但她把它压了下去，去工作了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I worked as much as I could, because honestly, when you're nervous, when you're anxious, it's really, really hard to get things done. I arrived really late to my house that day. I arrived at 8 o'clock. I arrived on the bus. When I get down off the bus on the corner of my house, my boss, she was the one that sent me the video.
我尽我所能工作，因为说实话，当你紧张，当你焦虑时，做事真的非常非常难。那天我回家很晚。我8点到的。我乘公共汽车。当我下公共汽车走到家门口时，我的老板，是她发给我的视频。
She tells me, Mari, I sent you this video. I think I saw your husband there. Take a look and let me know if it's him.
她告诉我，Mari，我发给你这个视频。我想我看到你丈夫在那里了。看看并让我知道是不是他。
She sent it to your phone, like a video on your phone?
她把它发到你手机上了，就像手机里的视频吗？
Si.
是的。
Yeah, it was a news clip, from Telemundo. And I click on the video, and the beginning is there were airplanes, getting to El Salvador, and a bunch of Venezuelans, people getting off the planes and all of that. But at the end, when the video was almost done, there's a moment where there's people kneeling down, getting shaved.
是的，那是一个来自Telemundo的新闻片段。我点击视频，开头是飞机，到达萨尔瓦多，一堆委内瑞拉人，人们下飞机等等。但在最后，当视频快结束时，有一个人们跪下被剃头的时刻。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
There, at 38 seconds in on the screen, was Mikael, profile sharp, curls falling around his face, his head held down while someone shaves his head. It lasts just a few seconds, and then the camera cuts to someone else. It was chilling, like a scene in some perverse movie.
那里，屏幕上38秒处，是Mikael，侧脸轮廓分明，卷发垂在脸颊周围，低着头，有人在给他剃头。它只持续了几秒钟，然后镜头切到了别人。这令人不寒而栗，就像某种反常电影里的场景。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I recognized him immediately. The second I saw him, I knew it was him. He has a tattoo, and it's a Chinese phrase, like on his sideburn. And, obviously, when they were shaving him, you could see it. And he has long, curly blonde hair, and he's the only one who had hair like that. I mean, it was him. It was him.
我立刻认出了他。我看到他的那一秒，我就知道是他。他有一个纹身，是中文短语，就在他的鬓角上。显然，当他们剃头时，你能看到它。他有着长长的、卷曲的金发，他是唯一一个有那样头发的人。我的意思是，是他。是他。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When I saw him, I went into crisis. I started shaking. I started crying. I was with another girl that lives with me, because we work in the same hotel. And I tell her, Josefina, it's him. Josefina, it's him. It's Mikael. They took him, and I just-- it was very bad.
当我看到他时，我陷入了危机。我开始发抖。我开始哭。我和住在一起的另一个女孩在一起，因为我们在同一家酒店工作。我告诉她，Josefina，是他。Josefina，是他。是Mikael。他们带走了他，我只是……情况非常糟糕。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I was telling her, Jose, it's him, it's him, it's him. And the first thing she told me was calm down, because something could happen to you. And all I could say was, Jose, it's him. They took him.
我告诉她，Jose，是他，是他，是他。她对我说的第一件事就是冷静点，因为你可能会出事。而我只能说，Jose，是他。他们带走了他。
I just felt so, so sad when I saw his face, like he was suffering. His eyes were swollen. He must have cried so much.
看到他的脸，我感到如此、如此悲伤，就像他在受苦一样。他的眼睛肿了。他一定哭得很厉害。
And then immediately, I went home. I turned on my computer, and I started to look, and immediately, I saw that he was-- he was no longer in the US system.
然后立刻，我回家了。我打开电脑，开始看，我立刻看到他——他不再在美国系统里了。
At that moment, Mari unknowingly became a data point, part of a group of people who figured out their loved ones were taken to a notoriously bad Salvadoran prison through a video.
那一刻，Mari不知不觉地成为了一个数据点，成为了一群通过视频发现亲人被带到臭名昭著的萨尔瓦多监狱的人中的一员。
A mom in Venezuela had the same experience at around the same time as Mari. She saw a close-up of her son Mervin Yamarte Fernandez's face on screen in the same Telemundo report, and that's how she knew where he was.
委内瑞拉的一位母亲在大约与Mari相同的时间经历了同样的经历。她在同一个Telemundo报道中看到了屏幕上她儿子Mervin Yamarte Fernandez脸部的特写，那就是她知道他身在何处的方式。
Another mom, same thing. Seeing a brief glimpse of his tattooed arms was the only marker of her son Francisco Garcia Casique and his whereabouts. Without these videos, they would have simply disappeared.
另一位母亲，同样的事情。瞥见他纹身的胳膊是她儿子Francisco Garcia Casique及其下落的唯一标记。没有这些视频，他们就会简单地消失。
I know people say unprecedented a lot, but I really can't think of another word to describe this swift and secretive removal of 238 Venezuelans. It happened so quickly. Within four hours of the Trump administration invoking the Alien Enemies Act, Mikael and the other 237 got removed. Mari described it to me as a kidnapping. And this move of shipping people who were in the US abroad to some dank prison is unlike anything I've seen in US immigration.
我知道人们常说“前所未有”，但我真的想不出另一个词来描述这种对238名委内瑞拉人迅速而秘密的移送。发生得太快了。特朗普政府援引《外籍敌侨法》的四个小时内，Mikael和其他237人就被移送了。Mari向我描述这为绑架。而且这种把在美国的人运送到国外某个阴暗监狱的举动，是我在美移民政策中从未见过的。
We've sent hundreds to the mega prison CECOT so far, and we're paying the Salvadoran government $6 million to hold them. It's described as a prison no one leaves alive. And it's next to impossible to talk to people who are there. Not even lawyers can.
到目前为止，我们已经把数百人送到了超级监狱CECOT，我们正在向萨尔瓦多政府支付600万美元来关押他们。它被描述为一座没有人能活着出来的监狱。而且与那里的人交谈是不可能的。连律师都不行。
The government is saying Mikael was sent there because he's a gang member, Tren de Aragua. So is he?
政府称Mikael被送往那里是因为他是帮派成员，Tren de Aragua。那么他是吗？
The New York Times and CBS have made these lists with all the men taken there, looked into whether they could find any criminal activity here in the US, in Venezuela, and in surrounding countries. And so far, it looks like almost 90% either have no record or have been charged with minor offenses, like driving with a suspended license or trespassing.
《纽约时报》和CBS列出了所有被带到那里的男性的名单，调查了他们是否能在美国、委内瑞拉及周边国家找到任何犯罪活动。到目前为止，看起来近90%的人要么没有犯罪记录，要么只被指控犯有轻微罪行，如无照驾驶或擅自闯入。
I talked to a professor named Dorothy Kronick, who's making one of these lists. She studies crime and policing in Venezuela. I asked her specifically about Mikael. She hasn't found anything suspicious.
我采访了一位名叫Dorothy Kronick的教授，她正在制作这些名单之一。她研究委内瑞拉的犯罪和治安。我特别问了她关于Mikael的情况。她没发现任何可疑之处。
I also asked a local reporter in his hometown, this small island off the coast of Venezuela. She told me that there is no Tren de Aragua activity there.
我还问了他家乡当地的一名记者，那是委内瑞拉海岸外的一个小岛。她告诉我那里没有Tren de Aragua活动。
Mikael lived in Colombia for a while. I did a criminal record search there, using his Venezuelan government ID number. Nothing.
Mikael在哥伦比亚待过一段时间。我使用他的委内瑞拉政府身份证号码在那里进行了犯罪记录搜索。什么都没有。
This lack of information connecting Mikael to Tren de Aragua, that doesn't seem to deter our government. Robert Cerna, an acting field office director for ICE's removal operations, said something that stuck with me. Quote, "The lack of specific information about each individual actually highlights the risk they pose. It demonstrates that they are terrorists, with regard to whom we lack a complete profile." So according to the government, no proof that you're a criminal is the greatest proof of all.
这种缺乏连接Mikael和Tren de Aragua的信息的情况，似乎并没有阻止我们的政府。ICE移送行动的代理现场办公室主任Robert Cerna说了一句让我印象深刻的话。引用：“缺乏关于每个人的具体信息实际上凸显了他们构成的风险。这表明他们是恐怖分子，关于他们我们缺乏完整的资料。”所以根据政府的说法，没有证据表明你是罪犯就是最伟大的证据。
Mari is convinced that Mikael's tattoos, that's the only reason the government thinks he's a gang member, which is not crazy. The government is looking at tattoos. They have a list of Tren de Aragua suspicious tattoos, and it is broad-- trains, crowns, roses, clocks, star, a Michael Jordan. If this is a list of gang tattoos, everyone under 50 is in a gang.
Mari确信Mikael的纹身，那是政府认为他是帮派成员的唯一原因，这并不疯狂。政府正在看纹身。他们有一份Tren de Aragua可疑纹身名单，而且范围很广——火车、皇冠、玫瑰、时钟、星星、迈克尔·乔丹。如果这是一份帮派纹身名单，那50岁以下的人都在帮派里。
Ronna Risquez, a Venezuelan reporter who has been following Tren de Aragua for 10 years and wrote the book about them, told me two things. One, as far as she knows, there are no Tren de Aragua specific tattoos, so basing anything on tattoos is ridiculous. To be fair, the government says they're relying on more than just tattoos, but it's unclear in a lot of cases what else. And two, Ronna confirmed what the local reporter said, that the place Mikael is from has no Tren de Aragua activity at all.
Ronna Risquez，一位关注Tren de Aragua 10年并写了关于他们的书的委内瑞拉记者，告诉了我两件事。一，据她所知，没有Tren de Aragua特定的纹身，所以基于纹身做任何判断都是荒谬的。平心而论，政府说他们依赖的不止是纹身，但在许多情况下，还不清楚其他是什么。二，Ronna证实了当地记者所说的，即Mikael来自的地方根本没有Tren de Aragua活动。
Mari scoffs at the idea that Mikael is some secret Tren de Aragua operative who could hide from the biggest snoop of all, her.
Mari对Mikael是一个秘密的Tren de Aragua特工、可以躲过最大的“窥探者”——她，这种想法嗤之以鼻。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I mean, when you're with someone, you're going to notice if he's into something weird or not. And, I'm a very toxic person. Bueno, not toxic. Like, I'm not toxic when it comes to women, but I like to be on top of what he's doing all the time.
我的意思是，当你和某人在一起时，你会注意到他是否参与了奇怪的事情。而且，我是一个非常“有毒”的人。好的，不是有毒。就像，当涉及女性时我不有毒，但我喜欢一直掌握他正在做什么。
I go through all his things. I go through his phone. I spent a lot of time with him at the barber shop. We were always making video calls while he was working, while I was working. It was always 24 hours a day we were in communication, we were in touch. And he's the same. He was-- he was more toxic than me.
我查看他所有的东西。我查看他的手机。我在理发店花了很多时间陪他。当他工作时，当我工作时，我们总是进行视频通话。我们一直24小时在交流，我们有联系。他也是一样。他——他比我还“有毒”。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
What Mikael is is an asylum seeker. Regardless of what his asylum claim is and whether or not you think he should get asylum, I want you to put that aside for a moment. He's in the middle of a legal process that he followed our laws to participate in.
Mikael是寻求庇护者。无论他的庇护主张是什么，无论你是否认为他应该获得庇护，我想请你把那个放在一边。他正处于一个法律程序中，他遵循我们的法律参与其中。
I cannot overstate how crazy it is that he and others got picked up and shipped away, like we just pretended due process doesn't exist anymore. Normally, someone like Mikael would present all his evidence to a judge-- documents, testimony. And then the judge would decide if under our law Mikael could stay or if he should be deported. That's what due process is, getting to stand in court and prove who you are, where you should be. Without it, the government could send anyone to CECOT. Without due process, you have no say.
我无法夸大他是如何像那样被抓走并被运走是多么疯狂，就像我们假装正当程序不再存在了一样。通常，像Mikael这样的人会向法官提交所有证据——文件、证词。然后法官会决定在我们的法律下Mikael是否能留下或是否应该被驱逐。那就是正当程序，有机会站在法庭上证明你是谁，你应该在哪里。没有它，政府可以把任何人送到CECOT。没有正当程序，你没有发言权。
Immediately after seeing the head shaving video, Mari gets herself together and calls for help, calls Mikael's lawyer. She's like, the lawyer will know what to do.
在看到剃头视频后，Mari立即让自己振作起来并呼叫求助，打电话给Mikael的律师。她想，律师会知道该怎么办。
The lawyer does not know what to do. The lawyer is in shock. She told me she's never seen anything like this in over 20 years of legal practice. She can't get a hold of Mikael at all. The next day is his next hearing with the judge.
律师不知道该怎么办。律师处于震惊中。她告诉我她从业20多年来从未见过这样的事情。她根本联系不到Mikael。第二天是他与法官的下一次听证会。
The lawyer told me that during that hearing, the judge kept calling Mikael's name. Subero? Subero? Where is Subero? The detention center didn't know. The ICE attorney didn't know. Mari was there listening in on Zoom.
律师告诉我，在听证会期间，法官一直呼喊Mikael的名字。“Subero？Subero？Subero在哪里？”拘留中心不知道。ICE律师不知道。Mari在Zoom上听着。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
They were waiting for Mikael to come on the video call that they were doing for the correctional facility where he was, which is in Pennsylvania. Mikael never came out. The cops would say nothing. The cops wouldn't give a reason. All they would say was that they were looking for him.
他们正在等待Mikael出现在他们为他所在的惩教设施进行的视频通话上，该设施在宾夕法尼亚州。Mikael从来没出来。警察什么也没说。警察不会给出理由。他们唯一会说的就是他们正在找他。
Whoa, so no one in the court knew where he was, either?
哇，所以法庭上也没有人知道他在哪里？
No.
没有。
Throughout this story, I felt a lot like Mari, turning to scholars, to lawyers, to think tanks that track immigration for decades to ask, what exactly is this? What's happening? And the response, over and over again, was they have no idea. Everyone is wading into new water.
在整个故事中，我感觉很像Mari，求助于学者、律师、追踪移民几十年的智库，问：这到底是什么？发生了什么？而答案，一次又一次，是他们也不知道。每个人都在踏入新的水域。
Mari hasn't heard from Mikael in over a month.
Mari已经一个多月没收到Mikael的消息了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Sometimes I get to work, and I'm doing whatever, and I'm like, oh, I feel like calling Mikael to see what's going on at the barber shop. And then, obviously, I remember that he's not here anymore, that I can't do that.
有时我去工作，我在做任何事情，我想，哦，我觉得应该打电话给Mikael，看看理发店那边怎么样。然后，显然，我记得他不再在这里了，我不能那样做。
When was the last time a moment like that happened for you?
这种时刻最后一次发生在你是什么时候？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Literally every day that I go to work. In the mornings, it's always the first thing that comes to my mind. Because every day when I get to work, it's the time he would call me always to say, are you OK? Did you have breakfast-- to see if I had breakfast. I always-- like, I wait for the call. I hear the phone ringing, and I'm like, it's Mikael, and like that. And that's what it's like. And it's like-- it's like the hardest thing.
字面上每天我上班时。早上，这总是我脑海中闪过的第一件事。因为每天当我到工作时，那是他总是打电话问我“你还好吗？吃过早餐了吗”的时候——看看我是否吃了早餐。我总是——就像，我等待那个电话。我听到手机响，我就想，是Mikael，就像那样。这就是那种感觉。而且它就像——就像最难的事情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
She can't stay in their apartment anymore because the raid was so intense. She didn't want to touch his stuff, because she kept thinking he'd be back. Some days, she says, she doesn't know what to do with herself. She feels angry all the time, tricked. Disappearing people in the middle of the night, taking them someplace where you can't see them or talk to them, that's not a US thing. She never thought something like this could happen here. Many people didn't.
她不能再呆在他们的公寓了，因为那次搜查太强烈了。她不想碰他的东西，因为她一直以为他会回来。她说有些天，她不知道该拿自己怎么办。她一直感到生气、被耍了。在深夜带走人，把他们带到你看不到或联系不到他们的地方，那不是美国的事情。她从没想过这种事情会发生在这里。许多人也没想到。
Nadia Reiman is an editor on our show. Interpreting for this story by Anayansi Diaz-Cortes.
Nadia Reiman是我们节目的编辑。Anayansi Diaz-Cortes为这个故事担任翻译。
Our program was produced today by Valerie Kipnis. Our executive editor Emanuele Berry edited the show. The people who put together today's program include Phia Bennin, Mike Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Emanuel Dzotsi, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Laura Starecheski, Nancy Updike, James Williamson, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由Valerie Kipnis制作。我们的执行编辑Emanuele Berry编辑了这期节目。今天节目制作人员包括Phia Bennin、Mike Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Emanuel Dzotsi、Angela Gervasi、Cassie Howley、Seth Lind、Tobin Low、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson、Ryan Rumery、Marisa Robertson-Textor、Alissa Shipp、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala、Laura Starecheski、Nancy Updike、James Williamson和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive producer is Ira Glass.
我们的管理编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行制作人是Ira Glass。
Special thanks today to Yael Even Or, Jeremy Ashkenas, Aaron Reicklin-Melnick, Muzaffar Chishti, Stephen Yale-Loehr, Julie Turkewitz, Carolina Arias Ipys, Dara Lind, Josbelk Gonzalez Mejias, Galya Walt, Breaking the Silence, and the Chronicle for Higher Education. Casting help from Sabrina Hyman.
今天特别感谢Yael Even Or、Jeremy Ashkenas、Aaron Reicklin-Melnick、Muzaffar Chishti、Stephen Yale-Loehr、Julie Turkewitz、Carolina Arias Ipys、Dara Lind、Josbelk Gonzalez Mejias、Galya Walt、Breaking the Silence和《高等教育纪事报》。选角帮助来自Sabrina Hyman。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you become a This American Life partner, you will get bonus episodes, ad-free listening, and more. The latest bonus episode is an Ask Me Anything episode, where Ira Glass answered questions sent in by subscribers. To hear it, and get all the other perks, and, most importantly, help us keep making the show, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。如果您成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，您将获得奖励剧集、无广告收听等更多福利。最新的奖励剧集是“问我任何事”剧集，Ira Glass回答了订户发来的问题。要收听它，并获得所有其他优惠，最重要的是，帮助我们保持制作节目的能力，请前往thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目说明中。
Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. He went to a Hugh Grant convention this year. Everyone dressed up-- Four Weddings and a Funeral Hugh, Notting Hill Hugh, Love Actually Hugh.
一如既往地感谢我的老板Ira Glass。他今年参加了一个休·格兰特大会。每个人都装扮成：《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》里的休，《诺丁山》里的休，《真爱至上》里的休。
We're talking about at least 18,000 grants.
我们谈论的是至少18,000份申请书。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。下周我们将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。